اسحاب في الدعم العسكري المقدم لاوكرانيا
بدا يهدد مخزون الولايات المتحده من
الذخائر بالنفاذ وفقه مركز دراسات
استراتيجيه الدوليه واشنطن ارسلت اكثر من
مليون قذيفه من عيار 155 ملم بما فيها
قذائف دقيقه التوجيه خلال عام تقريبا
تستغرق القاعده الصناعيه حوالي خمس سنوات
لتجديدها خطوط حمراء اخرى قطعتها الولايات
المتحده مع تقديم خمسه الاف ومئتين صاروخ
اسكاليبر الموجهه بدقه المفارقه انها ترسل
حوالي 1000 صاروخ شهريا رغم ان انتاجها
الثانويه يبلغ صاروخ سنويا استبدال
مخزونات هذا نوع من ذخيره يتطلب سبع سنوات
وادعوا مماثل بالنسبه لصواريخ المضاده
للدبابات والسنجر المضاده للطائرات ارسل
منها مشاهدينا تباع ثمانيه الاف 1500
صاروخ و1600 صاروخ صنع هذه صنع هذه القطع
يحتاج بين ست وثمان سنوات هذه السنوات
المطلوبه لتجديد مخزون همم الاسلحه
الامريكيه تطلق جرس انذار على جهتين اولا
حاجه الجيش الامريكي الى الذخيره
للتدريبات وكذلك في حال اندلاع اي حال
ثانيا امكانيه اضطرار اوكرانيا لتقنين
القذائف واطلاق النار على الاهداف ذات
الاولويه القصوى فقط او استخدام ذخيره اخف
واقصر مدى واقل فتك فاكرانيا مشاهدينا
تطلق نحو
143,000 قذيفه في الشهر اي ما يقارب من
اربعه الاف و700 قذيفه يوميا تقليله هذا
العدد شرط غير مقبول بالطبع بالنسبه
للاوكرانيين يستوجب تدخل جيوش اخرى
لمرحله ماء كمصادر للقضاء في المدفعيه مع
ترجيحاته بان تملا كوريا الجنوبيه هذا
الفراغ
[موسيقى]